بعد روايات متضاربه اكدت مجموعه فاجنر
الروسيه سيطرتها على مدينه سوليدر شرق
اوكرانيا ومقتل 500 جندي اوكراني خالفت
فاجنر رغبه الكراملين الذي اكد اهميه عدم
التسرع في اعلان الانتصار في سوليدار
وانتظار الاعلان الرسمي مشيرا الى وجود
تقدم للقوات الروسيه في البلده بدورها
قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان قواتها
حاصرت سولدار من الشمال والجنوب بينما قصف
سلاح الجو مواقع اوكرانيا في البلده هذا
الاعلان سبقه تاكيد قائد مجموعه
سيطروا على سوليدار بعد معارك كثيفه خلال
الاسبوع الحالي مضيفا ان قتال الشوارع
متوسط الجيش الاوكراني الطرف الاهم في
المعادله اصدر بيانا قد يبدو ياسا مؤكدا
ان البلده ستبقى اوكرانيه تصريحات لا
تحتاج لتفسيرات توضح انها مس وقت وستكون
سوليدار تحت سيطره روسيا
كل ما يدور اليوم في اتجاه باخ موت او
سوليدار هو سيناريو الاكثر دمويه لهذه
الحرب اي اننا نرى مثل هذا الموقف غير
المسؤول تماما بعباره اكثر لطفا موقف
النخبه الروسيه تجاه افرادها العسكريين
الذين يموتون هناك بالالاف هناك الكثير من
الدماء والمعارك بالمدفع عند خاصه في
سوريا دار اليوم هذه هي البقعه الاكثر
سخونه في الحرب
السيطره على سوليدار قد لا تغير وجه
المعركه من الناحيه الاستراتيجيه ولكن
معنويا سيكون المفعول كبيرا اذ تتصارع
القوات الروسيه والاكرانيه عليها منذ اشهر
لدرجه ان الحياه فيها باتت غير موجوده من
شده القتال لكن سقوط سوليدار قد يمثل نقطه
انطلاق للقوات الروسيه من اجل تطبيق مدينه
القريبه التي تسع روسيا طيب سيطر عليها
منذ الصيف الماضي وتقعوا على خط امداد
استراتيجي بين منطقتين يتسكو ولوغانسكا
اللتين تتالف منهما من تقدم بس اهم منطقه
صناعيه في اوكرانيا ومن شان السيطره على
مخنوقه منح روسيا منطلقا للتقدم نحو
مدينتين اكبر هما الكرامتوسك
وسلوفيانسكار وبحسب المخابرات البريطانيه
فان روسيا تسعى على الارجح من خلال محورها
في سوليدار الى تطبيق من الشمال وتعطيل
خطوط التواصل الاوكرانيه رائد الاخبار معه
المسجد
اكدت الدفاع الروسيه ان جيشها سيطر على
المناطق الشماليه والشرقيه من مدينه
سيلدار واضافت ان معارك ضاريه ما زالت وسط
المدينه وقل قائد قوات فاجنر الخاصه ان
جنوده سيطروا على وسط المدينه وطهروها من
ديول المقاتلين الاوكرانيين في ذات الوقت
الذي ما زالت فيه معارك ضاريه بين الجيش
الاوكراني والروسي في مناطق غرب المدينه
وتشير مصادره الى وصول امدادات عسكريه
اوكرانيه الى نفس المحور لتعزيز دفاعاتكيه
بينما تتقدم القوات الروسيه من المحور
الشمالي نفسه للوصول الى مدينه سيفر التي
يسيطر عليها الجيش الاوكراني شمالا مقاطعه
دانيسك بينما تطوق كامل القوات الروسيه
مدينه باخمط وتنطلق من بلده اوفتنا نحو
العمقي في تلك المدينه نحو مدينه ايفانكا
[موسيقى]